So this is the basic definition of a pinhole camera or a camera obscura.
The basic idea is that if you have a 3D scene and if you can
create a small device like this one, which basically has a small hole,
a pinhole, then all the light from this 3D scene would go through this pinhole.
And if you put some sort of a screen or a sensor inside this box,
it'll appear upside down inside this box.
The simplest definition of a camera, therefore, would be as basically how light
goes through this hole, is generated upside down in the back of this box.
And if you notice, all the light is basically going in from one hole and
appearing upside down here.
And now, of course, the simplest thing we can do to make this
into a camera that would preserve this image,
would be to be able to store this image in some form or the other.
I'm just showing you a few more examples.
These are the classic examples of pinhole cameras.
And I did mention earlier that this definition of
a camera has existed from about three to 400 BC.
Where you would put a light source here, go through a pinhole, and
an image would be formed upside down inside the box.
And this was a classic method used in the old days also, where basically 3D
scenes like this would actually be captured through a pinhole upside down.
And people would actually use various types of sketching mechanisms to
preserve this.
And they would actually do sketching or painting on a wall to preserve this.
Of course, we have many different methods of preserving this, and
there's a whole lot of stuff about both films, and
of course, digital sensors that can do this.